hi we are katherine mcnamara and matthew
d'addario
and we are here with buzzfeed today to
take a quiz to find out how well we
actually know each other i think we know
each other pretty well matt we spend a
lot of time each other damn well
in fact i think we're going to prove it
here with this first question let's find
out
[Music]
what is your birthday i assume did you
know mine i do know your birthday
november 22nd very good
got it we nailed it you both checked
that out definitely your birthday now
this is gonna be a problem because
that's that might be where it begins and
ends and what i know
their astrological sign i think that
makes you a libra
i don't know the astrological science
you could be
the scorpion i am that's half right so
you should count it because i'm
i'm on the cusp day so i'm telling you
you're on the cusp day
yeah so i'm scoring right now i took
from what i know
and i applied it your parents and
siblings
i know your mom's name you do yeah
because it was a name that stuck with me
because it's
not a name i i see frequently your
mother's name is ursula
it is you don't have any siblings and i
wish i knew your grandparents
names but i don't know that's okay
you'll meet them eventually i'm sorry
okay
they adore you your siblings names are
alex
and catherine very good your dad's name
is richard ah right
and your mom's name is christina
oh my good lord almighty you you are
absolutely correct that is incredible i
feel so
known so understood what friends are
for the first time we met oh i remember
i don't remember the date i don't
remember the day i'm assuming
the location is probably the the that
dinner we went to or lunch we went to we
met in the lobby of that hotel
in toronto i remember my first
impression of you you were very tall
that was my first time he's very tall i
don't know what my first impression of
you was
not i don't remember their favorite
movie or tv show of all time
okay i don't know your favorite of all
time but i do know one that you love
because you've recommended it to me
bojack horseman
ah i've recommended that yeah
it's not my favorite show of all time no
but then again we shouldn't play
favorites
with anything no it's not right to do
that
i'll be wrong so i think in terms of
favorite movie or tv show of all time i
don't have a good answer for you tell me
what your favorite movie is all the time
i gotta know
one of my favorites is gilda with rita
hayworth from
1936 i want to say oh yeah
me too but but princess bride is if i
have to pick one
i think you've mentioned the princess
bro that's right that's right
okay i didn't get that one so i don't
get to click it i don't think i did
either
acting job i know you did that play
with lansbury right yeah i don't know
what the play was
that's okay that counts i think that
counts that was your first like big
thing right that was what brought you to
new york
yeah i know that because that's super
cool frankly
yours was also super cool if it's the
one that i know of was delivery man your
first acting job
no but that's that's that's back there
no i my first one
really is breathe in oh right
yeah the jeremiah's film by drake dramas
which is a good film i think it's an
underrated flick
i think you should go check it out we
should check it out your favorite snack
you like potato potato chips potatoes i
like potatoes apples are usually my
go-to
that's close but i don't get that one i
don't get that what's my favorite snack
i feel like when i imagine what your
favorite snack would be
your ideal would be like some amazingly
curated charcuterie board
am i saying that right you know with
like some good meat
for me what am i it's some kind of fancy
you're not wrong
but everyone likes that everyone wants
some cheese and meat on a plat on a
platter
that's not like a snack that's like a
that's a whole that's a whole meal
chicharrones i like pork lemons that's
my favorite snack and there's big ones
at the
velarco down in california here big
giant you can imagine i'll take a photo
with one as big as me
the whole side of the thing yeah you
gotta check it out
oh yeah i i gotta i'll take you up to
the velarta it's a whole it's a it's a
mystery let me tell you what
he's peppy i think we get along so well
it's not much
and flusters you not much annoying yeah
i'm not going to get worked yeah yeah
we're not going to get worked up about
something
it's silly nothing i think if any if i
had to think of anything that would bug
you
it would be if we were all in a group
setting and somebody wasn't
like down to have fun and wasn't kind of
relaxing and enjoying but then that's
when you step in and you sort of
yeah you gotta fix it you gotta adapt to
the situation and help them out
right i think you're the same way i've
never seen you get aggravated over some
nothing
no pet peeves are that's my biggest pet
peeve is people with pet peeves it's
ridiculous it's silly
so let's i i think we're on the same
page which counts as knowing
the other person so i think we both get
that one i love that idea favorite
alcohol beverage i know yours and i
think i know yours
um yours is definitely oh i'm going with
scotch
thanks to you actually you sat me down i
used to drink whiskey only and kind of
was
experimenting with different things and
you sat me down one day and said today
you drink scotch and i've never tried
this
yeah i think honestly it's if you're
going to drink like you're not a big
mixed drink person you're not a big beer
person so
why not go with scotch i mean it's tasty
i would say either scotch
or personality juice oh
personality juice personality juice is
pretty fantastic
i can't believe you know about
personality juice i guess i you forget
the times that you drink personality
juice it just gives you so much
personality that's true
let's go with personality juice scotch
is also correct i think we both got it
right
and never tell anyone what personality
juice is that's a trade secret you can't
let anyone know that's that's
the finest drink that exists their
hidden talent can you lick your elbow
i cannot lick my elbow okay so i got
that one i got long
long arms doesn't quite reach aside from
things like knitting and baking
i'm good at tetrising items in a
suitcase i think we've all become quite
good at that you know that's something
i'm good at
too i think that you spent like 24 hours
baking once
it was actually i was eating them and i
was thinking there's no way she made
these
but you did it's unbelievable i think
just things that you can't get at the
bakery because they're like no i'm not
going to make that that's too
time consuming and you did it hand
delivered it there is a hidden talent
for you though that a lot of people may
not know aside from your
your just intelligence and your google
skills
i would say that your ability to cook a
fantastic
state i i agree it should be discussed
in all kinds of environments give me a
grill oven give me a tin can and some
and some wood nothing will stop this man
from cooking a perfect stop their
biggest celebrity crush
oh my oh my you know i have no
damn idea i would say i can never answer
these these questions about
about co-workers you know you can't i
just don't know the answer
it's a tough one for me to answer you
got 9 out of 12.
oh my god me too it says you know
absolutely everything there is to know
about your best friend well it's not
true
that's right you've been in each other's
lives for a long time now and even
finished those sentences you're
basically the same person
seems unlikely but you know what i'll
take it i'll accept it i wouldn't say
we're basically the same person but i
would say we're very much on the same
wavelength
we're on the wavelength i'm a big fan of
this test i like it i think everybody
should go home and take this test
i agree go to buzzfeed.com and take the
test
thanks so much for having us buzzfeed
and be sure to check out trust our new
film
you